you were so funny doing comedy have you
ever wanted to do drama of course man
every comedian has the ability to turn
drama into comedy see myself I'm I'm a
thespian first of all let people to
notice they picked it clearly see me
laughing all the time inside this is the
pain is inside my body I cross the
patient at pain right it's in my body so
he'd be the snickering errors in the
pasta my favorite show I saw a movie
called underworld oh I love underworld
yeah now they go through hours of makeup
and all that cuff stuff kind of the like
in you know likings all right like a
werewolf kind of yeah Rika's and
vampires I love liking you know me I
love being able I can do a Lycan and I
don't need make-up a nun that stuff wait
you can get on motion behind it's not
the makeup and something make you a
Lycan it's the it's your emotion your
body all the cool things you can do you
think you're a good enough actor to
become like a Lycan slash werewolf just
through your acting ability seriously
[Applause]
[Applause]
everywhere I go okay I'm surprised when
you pull it out like I'll go to court
and fight a ticket a look at your honor
can you do and you cry are you good at
the big the guy who's crying because his
life's been ruined we tell you something
right now
Viola Davis hasn't got anything on me
you're a better actor than Viola Davis
people think tears is what makes a good
cry it's emotion emotion makes the good
cry okay see
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
to the best actor I've ever seen I'm
surprised you even ask me that I know
[Laughter]
now wait now how would I like and cry
yeah there's a little bit of rooster in
there too
you